la vie s'organise sur ce camp de fortune
un camp monté à la hâte dans la soirée
d'hier à la suite des événements lorsque
plusieurs centaines de migrants ont
tenté de franchir la clôture en fil de
fer barbelé la clôture qui sépare la
pologne de l'aiea biélorussie ayant été
refoulés par les soldats et policiers
polonais ils ont tout ils ont donc
décidé d'établir un campement ici un
campement de fortune comme vous pouvez
le voir les hommes en ce moment je
cherche du bois dans la forêt afin
d'entretenir les nombreux feux de camp
qui jonchent ce campement qui s'étale
sur plusieurs centaines de mètres le
long de la frontière polonaise 2500
personnes de 1500 migrants se trouverait
à l'heure actuelle dans ce camp et dans
un camp où on commence de plus en plus à
manquer d'eau et de nourriture
les enfants ont froid il fait trop froid
nous sommes ici depuis trois jours et
nous cherchons de l'eau avoir de l'eau
c'est très important pour nous toutes
les bouteilles sont vides les familles
et les enfants en ont besoin
peu importe si l'on doit payer les
associations quiconque pour nous
apporter de l'eau
sans cela les enfants souffriront trop
les gars me disent qu'ils n'ont ni
nourriture ni eau personnellement ça va
je peux tenir mais pas des enfants alors
s'il vous plaît aidez-nous
c'est entre autres à cet endroit de la
frontière que hier plusieurs centaines
de migrants ont tenté de franchir cette
clôture en fil de fer barbelé à l'heure
actuelle les soldats polonais sont en
train de réparer cette clôture qui a été
endommagé lors des événements d'hier ces
soldats polonais ils sont extrêmement
nombreux ils sont déjà plusieurs
centaines rien qu'à cet endroit de la
frontière et plusieurs milliers en tout
le long des près de 200 kilomètres de
frontière qui sépare la pologne de la
biélorussie à l'heure actuelle il est
environ 2500 migrants sur quelques
centaines de mètres le long de cette
clôture et il en a encore d'autres
plusieurs autres centaines qui sont dans
les bois un petit peu plus loin en vieux
le russie et ils ont cet objectif en
tête passer cette clôture passer de
l'autre côté
et atteindre la pologne l'union
européenne